c'est le tapis rouge déroulé pour les
enseignants
mélanie la douceur fraîchement sorti de
son congé de maternité
sélectionne les écoles qui les
intéressent j'attends un ligne en fait
pour parler à une direction donc on voit
les non dits les écoles sont ici on
au centre de service scolaire
marie-victorin sur la rive sud on a pris
le taureau par les cornes pour lutter
contre la pénurie de personnel c'est
l'opération granville embauché à grande
vitesse en une seule journée du speed
d'été ou selon l'expression populaire
plus de 500 personnes rencontrent deux
directeurs et directrices d'école les
aspirants profs et cliff par la suite
leurs préférences d'école sur un
formulaire le service des ressources
humaines rassemble tous ces formulaires
la essaye de faire ce qu'on appelle des
matches parfaits lente les carnivores
puis les directions d'établissement des
affectations
marie-france label directrice de l'école
frère romain a commencé comme enseignant
je les trouve très chanceux les
candidats parce que moi je me souviens
que je devais à l'arraché essayé de me
trouver un 3 4 jours semaine la hausse
substantielle du salaire des enseignants
accordée par le ministre roberge mais
aussi une mission de recrutement à
l'étranger durant son mandat porte fruit
anaïs passionne c'est ainsi fait
embaucher directement en france reste à
choisir son école
les chercher les caleçons joseph
pourront passer en maternelle 50 sur 400
postes à combler la journée permettrait
l'embauché d'environ 350 enseignants à
temps plein et à temps partiel mais s'il
embauche bat son plein et si toutes les
écoles n'ont pas cette chance ne s'est
pas représentatifs on voit dans
différents milieux on est un grande
recherche d'enseignants encore la
semaine dernière dans une tournée
médiatique annoncé aux médias la belle
seulement le ministre de l'éducation
affirmé de façon rassurante que 700
postes d'enseignants restait à combler
les postes sont encore ouverts moi j'ai
confiance qu'on va les conduire vers un
triste g jean françois roberge soutient
que chaque classe aura un enseignant un
adulte oui disent les syndicats
qualifient pas nécessairement et ce sera
parfois plusieurs remplaçants on sait
très bien que dans les milieux repos un
enfant en péril à la rentrée tout le
monde va s'en occuper y aura du monde
dans un club mais à quel coût
le prix les syndicats affirment depuis
une semaine que le ministre de
l'éducation minimise le problème des
vérifications effectuées par radio
canada démontrent un cafouillage dans la
transmission des données la veille de la
sortie médiatique du ministre radio
canada fait par exemple vu refuser une
demande sur le nombre de postes à
combler sous prétexte que les données
n'étaient pas disponibles le ministère
nous ensuite fourni le chiffre de 700
postes vacants puis de 924 pour revenir
à cette fin et regroupement des
directions d'école eux sont catégoriques
il faut doubler ce nombre nous on est
allé avec un chiffre conservateur parce
qu'on n'avait pas toutes les réponses de
l'ensemble des centres de service mais
on était capable quand même de deux
d'établir une sorte même tendance une
moyenne donc ont agréé par un chiffre
conservateur de 500 autres postes pour
un total de 1400 enseignants à ce total
il faut ajouter des centaines d'autres
postes à combler notamment chez les
éducatrices en services de garde et les
techniciennes en enseignement spécialisé
à la veille de la rentrée scolaire ici
julie marceau radio canada montréal